foreign
movie retrospective time and we're going
full Kubrick on this episode talking
about a [ __ ] classic doctor
Strangelove or how I learned to stop
worrying and love the bomb Masterpiece
it really is I don't know if it's my
favorite Kubrick film but I'm really
glad that we got to revisit it because I
hadn't seen it since I was a kid and I
forgot how [ __ ] funny it was oh my
God it's funny but it's true well yeah
that's that's why it's funny though I
mean well I don't know if you know but
this actually came from Kubrick's idea
because this is the only comedy that he
ever made and it's not like an outright
comedy it's more like a satire like a
black comedy yeah
um what he was going to do initially was
he had read this book called Red Alert
which was like a serious Cold War
Thriller type of thing where pretty much
the same scenario that happens in doctor
Strangelove happens but it's played
straight and he was so he was going to
do that he was going to make like a
scary like cold war Thriller and he
started writing the screenplay like
writing the adaptation and he's like I
kept running into problems where it's
like the absurdity of it just kept like
hitting me in the face and it's just
like seemed like there was a lot of
stuff that I had to take out to keep it
from being funny and then he was just
like why don't I just make it kind of
funny and just because like the
absurdity of it like just like I said it
kind of like whacked you upside the head
I think what happens sometimes is you
know um civilians when they start
finding out how military stuff actually
works like you know like when I was up
on the DMZ you know during the night
during the early 90s and it was cold war
stuff and just the way we operated is a
lot like it's it's following the same
philosophies as what you see in this
movie this is
it's very accurate in terms of the way
the systems are and how they work and I
think when a civilian sees them they
realize kinda
how mundane they are actually it's just
kind of
it's very
it's not foolproof you know it's just
it's something kind of by the seat of
the paths yeah there's codes and stuff
involved there's a chain of command
there's fail safes but things can go
wrong it always does no no plan really
survives contact with reality
and that's what this movie's about it's
like yeah
it's 1960s Cold War it's Cutting Edge
technology
but a lot of [ __ ] could go wrong a lot
of [ __ ] could go wrong
well what I think what is satirizing in
particular is the whole concept of
mutually assured destruction which was a
whole thing at the time that's what it's
that's what it's satirizing yeah um how
like the Ridiculousness of that concept
and the you know the people that kind of
advocated for it but some of the people
that were really into it like they
couldn't even like they uh they opposed
building like for example Fallout
shelters because they said no it has to
be like mutually assured destruction
that's the only way that we're gonna get
everybody to like not do it is if nobody
there's no defense if there's no defense
against it if nobody could survive it I
guess you could say it is absurd it's
ridiculous but it actually worked
um if you kill me and I will kill you
that will keep you from trying to kill
me but what it is what it is emphasizing
is how dangerous it is
it's not that it's absurd it's just very
dangerous and in the end when you find
out how it goes they're fighting they're
still fighting over it at the very very
end they're talking about the dam what
they call it the uh uh the mine shaft
Gap yeah you know what I mean so you can
you can take the thinking to the extreme
and yeah that's
it's kind of ridiculous but it is
something that they would do yeah well
like I said they're trying to win and
survive well yeah that's what he's
satirizing he's just kind of satirizing
the whole you know just the the end of
the world the whole like way that it
could come about like you have to laugh
because it's just like so yeah it's so
absurd that it could happen like that
because the thing about out it like I
you know if you've never seen doctor
Strangelove I kind of feel like it's one
of those movies that either everybody's
seen it or everybody is kind of like uh
kind of through cultural osmosis like
knows a lot about it but I mean it
posits this scenario where this one guy
like this one General he's a win
Commander yeah like with this one Wing
Commander like Ripper Jack Jack D Ripper
yeah um goes crazy and decides that he's
going to launch a nuclear strike against
the Russians like like I said and kind
of get but the thing about it is that
um you know without presidential
authorization but from what I've heard
that's that was actually something that
they yeah that that was something that
they did yeah so that was a real thing
it probably wasn't called what they what
they called it no in order to attack
Wing plan r
uh which was in plan R was
if Washington D.C and the had already
been struck and the chain of command was
broken a more Junior uh uh Commander
could launch right a retaliatory strike
but you would have to have that in the
system
if it wasn't in the system then the
enemy would make a priority of a sneak
attack against the [ __ ] top Fir and
to avoid retaliation
this is the whole thing it is kind of
funny it's the systems trying to
retaliate against one another and
planning the retaliation and it can get
quite extreme and
uh
uh haven't lived through it and been in
a Cold War Era military service
because it was so extreme I think it
kept both sides in check because they
weren't that [ __ ] crazy
um but in this movie it was a dude that
was crazy yeah well see that's what
they're saying and like when they
explain because there's a great scene
where George C Scott's character
um you know turkusen yeah jump jump
Ferguson who was based on Kurt Lemay who
was a World War II
hero slash villain he he was
Army Air corps Commander he supervised
the bombing campaigns in Japan [ __ ]
had we lost that war he would have been
a damn we all we would have been in war
criminals okay for the [ __ ] that he did
but he was Lemay was a tough dude man
real sharp and Bucky's kinda
kind of kind of uh modeled after Kurt
Lemay
so that's who they're talking about yeah
everybody in this is sort of loosely
based on a real person or a
conglomeration of people just
exaggerated for a comedic effect but
what I was going to say is that there's
a scene where uh where buff turgusin is
explaining to the president uh who's uh
you know played by uh played by uh Peter
Sellers in one of his three roles in
this that
um you know and the reason that he has
that they had for having this law were
like a junior you know a person could
launch the codes without the president's
approval it's you're like well yeah they
probably would have that because they
had a good reason for it but you can
kind of see how in a situation like this
where one dude just went like completely
crazy about his precious bodily fluids
and all this other kind of stuff and
decided that he was gonna launch a thing
and then they couldn't really take it
back so then like the whole like
unfolding like insanity the movie is
them trying to like take it back and
like bring back all the planes that are
actually going to bomb Russia in defense
of the system they were able to recall
them except for that one but there was
one planned ahead of damage radar uh
radio yeah all right and they couldn't
they couldn't recall it
and
has something like that happened where
they couldn't recall one and the Soviets
knew what the hell went on they probably
just would have taken the blow
because they would have just struck
something like a ICBM site or something
like that
which so the Soviets could take that
damage and not retaliate because and
then they'd get all kinds of money and
[ __ ] from reparations for a nuclear
accident and they'd play that up for
[ __ ] 30 40 years the Soviets would
love it if that the Soviet Empire would
play that up but see that's why and what
they didn't know about the Doomsday
that's what I'm saying that's where they
had to put in the whole doomsday look
he's like oh yeah the Doom stated right
he thought it was where do we have one
of those
more [ __ ] Soviet [ __ ] you know
that's one of that call me propaganda
yeah where they just said well we can't
afford all this [ __ ] high-tech [ __ ]
so we're just gonna bury these bombs to
the ground and Lace them with what would
they call it some Cobalt thorium yeah
which has a real [ __ ] long
radioactive Half-Life and it would just
poison the Earth and just destroy
everyone on the earth if you ever
[ __ ] touched it and like no one and
like no one person was in control of it
it would just do it automatically and
you couldn't turn it off so yeah so so
they almost kind of had so it was like
this ESC relating absurdity of you know
yes they were able to recall most of the
planes except for that one whose radio
was broken and they couldn't get the
code Strange Love is in there he's
hiding in he's in the in the war [ __ ]
room okay and he's he's modeled after
Verna Von Brown among other people yeah
but mostly Brown has hit the whole
[ __ ] wounded arm what he had when he
was first [ __ ] surrendered he had the
[ __ ] broken arm and he's smiling with
his [ __ ] cigarette looking I got some
Fernando Von Brown stories too [ __ ]
uh friend of my dad's [ __ ] was his
military guard in Mississippi that the
secret rocket base down in [ __ ]
Gulfport Mississippi told me all about
when I was working on his air
conditioner told me all about Werner Von
Brown what an [ __ ] he was okay if I
could his guards were his servants he'd
[ __ ] order them because he was so
important you know and then then later
Ronnie ran and asked
but uh Dr Strange left jumps forward he
goes well wait a minute you had this
doomsday device what good is it if you
don't tell anybody that you have it
you're like he figured that out real
quickly well we were going to announce
it at the upcoming [ __ ] party because
you know how much he likes surprises
yeah
[Laughter]
so they had and then they end up they
realized the Doomsday [ __ ] device is
going to go off so then they start
planning the [ __ ] ultimate [ __ ]
thing which is
to take a [ __ ] nucleus of humanity
and to go down into these damn mine
shafts and of course it's gonna be you
know the best people you know that you
selected by a computer
and in order to [ __ ] repopulate the
Earth after that 90 years has passed
you're gonna need a lot of females so
the ratio is going to be 10 females to
every one male at which case every dude
in this is like oh yeah yeah okay all
right and of course these women are
going to have to be selected for a
certain [ __ ] attributes that'll make
a man wanna just so I can get them all
pregnant basically is what they're
saying because that's a heavy [ __ ]
dude you know it's a heavy [ __ ] load
on a man you know so they're going to be
very stimulating in nature so they're
all like yeah yeah so even the even the
Russian guys even the Communist guys
they're like okay that's a good idea
good idea yeah we're gonna go down in
here so then then they start already
thinking about well wait a minute what
if they what are they doing in their
bunkers so they're already planning for
the next [ __ ] retaliatory so it's
really they're kind of just it's like a
satire on the damn Stranglehold the US
Empire the Soviet Empire had around each
other during the [ __ ] cold war
they kept each other in check but it was
dangerous
I think a lot of I think a lot of people
too like you kind of I mean the the
satire of the Cold War and everything
like that and you know burner Von Brown
being the model for Doctor Strangelove
or anything like that that's all pretty
obvious if you know like uh about the
politics of the time period and like
what was going on at that time period
but I feel like a lot of people less
people get the whole sexual undercurrent
where everything is just kind of like
phallic yeah and everything is like
sexual frustration like everything is
couched in a language of like sexual
frustration or like in sexual terms you
know it was 1960s yeah and
um these Alpha level [ __ ] military
industrial complex type dudes back in
the 60s we're known for being married
and have multiple [ __ ] secretaries
that were girlfriends and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] that was their lifestyle they
were
they had it made that the in and yeah
that there was a lot of testosterone
going on in that era because they had
just basically they were
the ruling class of of the winning
Empire that had made it through world
World War II
and when
the government
the military
and corporations had merged into one
thing some people might call that
fascism okay but once it had merged into
one thing the military industrial
political complex they ruled the world
at least in their hemispheres so they
just had they could do whatever they
wanted they had all the money all the
[ __ ] power
women
you know and not just Americans Wonder
Von Brown had a [ __ ] ton of girlfriends
women loved him
he was a good looking guy he was ex-nazi
and an Ardent Nazi but he was working on
the American side and then ended up
running NASA did the whole [ __ ]
moonshot stuff and everything
and um
so yeah it's just the way that the way
culture was back then
yeah but like I was saying that was
that's another thing that the movie is
satirizing it's kind of satirizing the
whole I mean particularly I think the
most uh egregious example of that is
Slim Pickens at the end like riding the
bomb yeah like down on the thing but
also when you have a bull though too
when you had like Jack D Ripper like
with that big huge gun that he had like
in the golf bag and he's holding it like
that and he's like telling the other guy
to hold it with him like help him hold
it and all this other kind of stuff so
it's like they he was very aware and I
think it's funny because Stanley Kubrick
said like later on that somebody had
written him a fan letter and said about
like all the sexual stuff in there and
he's like oh I'm glad somebody picked up
on that because it's like there's a
bunch of stuff that he put in there like
there's lots of shots of like uh Jack D
Ripper with that big cigar like popping
out his mouth and Tim talking about his
bodily fluids and he's denying women his
Essence and all this stuff but he's not
avoiding women he's just denying him
yeah he he he kind of
there's a lot of good [ __ ] and if Peter
Sellers plays like five four he's three
characters he was actually supposed to
play four characters he was supposed to
play The Slim Pickens character too I
don't know Slim Pickens is [ __ ] here
but well yeah but what ended up
happening I'm bad with the roost Keys
yeah yeah what ended up happening with
that was that there was a bunch of
things he was just kind of like well he
was afraid that he wasn't going to get
the accent right yeah like he practiced
in practice and he's like I just feel
like it wasn't good enough and so he
didn't really want to do it and he's
like look I'm already playing three
parts and he was getting kind of worn
out
um but then it ended up like he hurt his
ankle or he broke his ankle and he
couldn't like get into the set like the
the B-52 set and uh so they were like
okay so they got Slim Pickens and said
which actually is like really really
great because Slim Pickens is [ __ ]
hilarious in this another thing that I
heard too is that they didn't tell Slim
Pickens this was a comedy and they just
let him play it straight so that's just
him yeah well you see we haven't got on
this subject yet the Bomber Crew is
awesome all right
the Bomber Crew is supposed to represent
like the Pinnacle of American Technology
and bravery these are these are the best
that America has inside a [ __ ] B-52
with their best Atomic weaponry and
their best [ __ ] secured radios and
their best training and these guys are
going up insurmountable odds they even
they even go toe-to-toe with a
nuclear-tipped anti-aircraft missile
that they they they survived that all
the the entire Soviet Air Force is
bearing down on them to try to stop them
from delivering this bomb and they make
it through and drop the bomb [ __ ]
just like Heroes and [ __ ] yeah
Flynn Pickens actually goes down into
the Bombay to [ __ ] rig the doors to
make sure that they open because they
wouldn't open gets on top of the bomb
and when they drop it he rides it down
to the Target
and it's just like the Pinnacle of
American alphaness okay they're doing
what they're told to do and unbeknownst
to them the whole mission was scrapped
it was a [ __ ] it never should have
been ordered the president was trying to
help the Soviets hunt the plane down to
stop it because they didn't know about
the doomsday device they didn't know
that General Ripper [ __ ] illegally
[ __ ] issued the attack attack plan R
you know they didn't know they just did
what they were told yeah because he just
did it and really the only the only
thing the only reason that it was found
out was because uh the other another
character that's played by Peter Sellers
who was like the British RAF guy he um
he's like oh all this stuff is going on
but then like he had a radio like even
though Jack the Ripper told everybody to
um you know turn at all their radios but
he's happened to find one and he turned
it on and it was just like regular
civilian radio programming he's like
well this wouldn't happen if the Soviets
had attacked us so what the [ __ ] and so
he gets like locked into office with
Jack D Ripper and then when as he
figures out what's going on he's trying
to like get the code out of him so that
he can stop the plane yeah he's Royal
Air Force he's like an exchange officer
on an exchange program he's the he's
these rippers [ __ ] executive officer
one of you he figures out that the
[ __ ]
there was no the the the attack never
happened that Ripper's gone wrong there
shouldn't have been a much there
shouldn't have been a the Soviet attack
never happens there shouldn't have been
any launch codes given you know he tries
to get the damn
recall codes out of him but it's just
and it turned turns out [ __ ] uh
well
the recall code was Poe or e-o-p-e ope
something like that puritive Essence and
peace on Earth
and what's his name man Drake man Drake
yeah he's British as hell father [ __ ]
his name was mandrake
magic gets him to eventually tell him
how it dawned on him that
what was it that he that
where he came up with this uh purity of
essence thing and how he how he came to
the conclusion to launch and he said it
came to him while he was having sex uh
yeah basically what he said was uh he he
felt depleted afterwards yeah
and then it had to do with
that the Soviets had had
um fluoridated the water in order to
drain our pressure
yeah your precious
so I'm taking it based on what he said
was is that he had erectile dysfunction
yeah
and he thought it was the Soviets put in
Florida fluoride yeah essentially that's
that's what it's saying yeah
like I said it's almost kind of like
this whole movie is kind of like a
series of Dick jokes so
in order to deny the enemy of a victory
over him he would avoid women
yeah okay but he but then he would he
denied this well I'm not really avoiding
him I'm just denying them my Essence
yeah
and the Magic's like uh I see yeah like
oh [ __ ] so but it's kind of veiled
language but I that's how I interpret it
yeah that's exactly what he's talking
about yeah because he couldn't get it up
he couldn't get it he blamed the
Russians playing the Russians and
decided he was gonna like uh strike the
Russians for for Florida pretty much
destroy the whole world because he
couldn't get his dick so some Viagra
could have said
I mean the thing about it like I said I
forgot how [ __ ] funny this movie is
it's there's so many [ __ ] iconic
scenes some of my favorite scenes are
yeah like um or like Mandrake and uh
Ripper like in the office like the
conversation he's so [ __ ] good in
this I mean just like he's amazing he's
great as the president the whole that
whole extended sequence with the
president whose name is Merkin muffley
yeah a merkin is like a thing that you
put over your pubic hair yeah is what
that is yeah and then he's talking to
the prime Min the premiere yeah and the
phone and the premiere is obviously like
drunk and probably like with a hooker
but it's like the way that they're
talking to one another it almost sounds
like like a one of those old like Bob
Newhart like yeah
yeah well and it's like the funniest
thing is just the way that he's talking
talking to the guy is that are you upset
we can both be upset together
it's good that we're both fine
which that's Kubrick [ __ ] making the
statement that there are no real heroes
in this these are all these dudes are
all kind of [ __ ] up you know what I
mean that none of these systems can
really save you so so the politicians
are just a bunch of Kiss asses [ __ ]
the uh the the what do you call it the
Soviet Diplomat his name is kiss off
yeah and and he denied all kinds of [ __ ]
pretend to be a good good guy but he was
taking pictures of the little board the
big board the big board yeah we don't
see the big boards but it's kind of that
big because Bucky grabs him because look
he was trying to take it and he goes he
tried to plant that on me which he may
have which he may have but the president
believed it but then later on dude kiss
off was that did happen he had another
little camera that was taking pictures
of the big board after the [ __ ] so even
after even after it was too late
they're all a bunch of rats you know
what I mean if I get all of them
just funny you know I mean everything in
this is hilarious but yeah like the the
scenes I think the scenes of uh of uh
the president like talking to the
premier like on the phone because
they're like extended phone
conversations you can't hear the Russian
Premiere but you can tell kind of what's
being said by just what uh what Peter
Sellers is saying and it's just like the
way that he talks him is like [ __ ]
hilarious like the way that he's trying
to like broach the fact that uh someone
accidentally you know how we had those
discussions about what would happen like
if you know something happened with the
bombs the hydrogen bomb you know what I
mean and he's like well someone went and
did a silly thing you know what I mean
it was like that guy yeah like whatever
what I really liked though is uh they
showed the uh the the Bomber Crew
[ __ ] they're actually shown as
sympathetic they're [ __ ] super well
trained doing their job [ __ ] they're
gonna drop this bomb hell or high water
well they think
they're missing and they're really the
only competent [ __ ] out of this
whole system and they're being abused in
a way because
the mission was false and they didn't
they had no way they had no idea
because they even checked they were like
are we sure that that's what because
that's like pretty hardcore yeah they
called and checked and everything like
they like they did everything they were
supposed to yeah so the professionals on
the front lines are the really the only
sympathetic guys out of the whole
[ __ ] deal and the dudes that were
fighting their way in they said some
really good gunfight scenes they're done
in black and white it looks like real
combat footage with the with the
Airborne unit the Army Airborne unit
trying to fight the to fight the Air
Force Security to get into the base to
[ __ ] arrest a ripper and try to get
the [ __ ] recall codes that was great
scenes
um it looked real you even see bullet
impacts the scrib rounds they had way
they had them set up beautiful the only
problem I saw in that scene is that a
dude jumps up with a submachine got a
beautiful shot of him unloading into a
top story of a window it looked real as
[ __ ]
but the machine gun is an MP40 that's
German World War II everybody else had
yeah a lot of people have pointed that
out yeah that's a German gun but they're
not sure um if that was well they're not
sure I've seen different theories it's
like a Kubrick did that on purpose for
whatever reason or just because they got
that one because they thought it looked
enough like another one or something
yeah it looks like an M3 grease gun yeah
the other guys had M3s yeah maybe they
didn't have enough to go around so they
were like ads close enough although
usually I kind of feel like Kubrick
although this was one of his earlier
films but he's like kind of a known
Perfection they showed some other dudes
in M3s and they were just perfect shots
with M3s and and uh 303 uh uh m1919
belfed machine guns
the 30 off 6 machine guns and they're
just lighting it lighting up the [ __ ]
Army as they're coming across the open
field and it looks real the bullet
impacts look real and everything shaky
cam first time I've ever seen that in an
old movie
like it was done from well it's like a
documentary the combat food it's
supposed to look like they look really
good look really good I mean like I said
Kubrick like really because it's kind of
contrast that with like the really
really beautiful like especially the
shots of the War Room which I think are
like really great and like the lighting
in this which is like really kind of
very very like uh Kiara skiru it's very
like kind of harsh like light and dark
like looks really good but oh and
another one of the funniest scenes too
is when uh when he meets Keenan Nguyen
like as Kurt what was Colonel bat guano
or whatever and he comes and uh calls
him a preview calls him a pre-vert you
prevert and
and he's like and you know like poor man
Drake is trying to like call the
president on a [ __ ] pay phone uh to
tell him what the codes are to recall
the planes and he doesn't have enough
change yeah and he's like asking [ __ ]
guano for Change and he's like do you
think I can't like go into combat with
my pockets full of changes that you
don't and then yeah then like he's
saying it's like well go shoot that Coke
machine and it's like you know that's
what the bullets are for you twit or
something like that and then he's like
well you know if all of this shakes out
you're gonna have to answer to the
Coca-Cola Company like for blow it up
yeah for shooting the [ __ ] yeah we're
starting to get change out there was
something kind of struck me as true even
though that guy was a colonel
I think he was a colonel yeah he was a
full bird colonel and a furball for he
he was awful dumb for a full bird
colonel it's a comedy it's a comedy but
here's the thing when he showed up he
didn't know why they wanted Ripper he
didn't know anything about the launch of
the dam which that kinda Rings true
but I would think that a guy as high as
Colonel would know the situation maybe
they would maybe they wouldn't have told
him but
the gut in reality that the actual guy's
fighting to get inside the Air Force
Base wouldn't have really known why they
just it would just be get in there
penetrate the security arrest the
commander get him on the phone
and that's probably all they would have
known he would have known that he'd
launched
but I would think that they would have
told somebody as high as the full bird
colonel of why
but I don't know because he didn't know
about the launch which I thought that
was kind of strange
well like I said one it's a comedy and
they were you know if he did that on
purpose he's probably like trying to
make a you know make a point about it's
like oh one hand doesn't know what the
other hand is doing kind of thing yeah
there's no time or or the whole
situation was so chaotic that yeah it
wouldn't have liked Yeah well yeah
because they were like running around
like their chickens they were there they
got there what an hour later not even an
hour yeah I don't remember what the time
so it was thrown together quickly and
that that that that's true that's how
that would go the average person
wouldn't know why they would just get
real basic orders and it would be a
cluster [ __ ] all right well yeah because
when the whole thing like when they
first come in like to the discussion and
say hey we launched a thing and they
tell the president yeah
um what is like George C Scott says
something like 25 minutes like no like
the planes will be appearing like in
Russian airspace or whatever the [ __ ] so
yeah it was like a really really short
time because they didn't know because
like I said it was one guy that went
rogue and nobody knew that he had done
it until it was almost like too late and
the Bomber Crew if you're if you pay
attention closely there's a young James
Earl Jones all right Army Ranger from
Mississippi and Darth Vader okay and uh
he's looking great does a great [ __ ]
job on the Bomber Crew has a bunch of
lines and then what what about what
about what about Commander Khan after
they [ __ ] dropped him out and
everything it was just a good flick good
flick man it really is I mean it's a
[ __ ] classic and like I said I forgot
how [ __ ] funny it was particularly I
think the phone call scenes are my
favorite like I said with the president
of the brush I was just like laughing my
ass off but that whole scene like with
the phone booth and the the pay phone
and like guano and all that that was
like [ __ ] hysterical because that's
another thing that's like
super absurd it's like how absurd would
it be and it's like the all of the phone
Communications have been cut off all
that works is a pay phone you know you
have to like call and save the world and
you don't have enough change and like
The Operators giving you aggro about it
like well just like let you slide and
it's like said you have to like blow up
a Coke machine to get the money and the
dudes like all like he doesn't want to
do it because it's like oh you're gonna
answer the Coca-Cola Company yeah it's
just like that's it's that's [ __ ]
hilarious to me like that kind of stuff
is hilarious and honestly I kind of feel
like most people think that's hilarious
because this movie is generally regarded
as one of the best comedies of all time
uh Roger Ebert called it like probably
the most uh the funniest like political
satire of all time which it's definitely
up there I have to say I just looked on
because somebody said something I was
watching a review of it and they said
the Criterion Collection version of it
is so cool you go and look at it and it
has like the cover of it's cool and
everything like that but it comes with
the whole little package all of the um
extras like all the essays and stuff
that people have written about the movie
they come in little packets you know the
packets are like Wing plan r or whatever
the hell like the little envelopes yeah
they all come in like little envelopes
like that and it comes with a little the
little
um miniature Bible slash phrase
I don't know because that was like the
whole yeah the survive
one Whatever prophylactic one two pairs
of nylons yeah
you can have a real fun time in Vegas
with that you know what the original
line was actually you could have a fun
time in Dallas with that but they
changed it because of the Kennedy
assassination because this said it came
out only after in 1964. that [ __ ] wasn't
as ridiculous as you think things like
lipsticks and nylons would have been
very valuable in the Soviet Union so
maybe they might have included something
like that in a survival packet because a
down pilot might be able to trade those
for something yeah but well that's the
thing it's like I think the best comedy
and the reason why a lot of people like
this satire and the best satire it's
funnier like the closer to the truth it
is you know what I mean because you have
to take something that's true and like
point out the absurdity of it too yeah
it is funny it is a comedy but it's also
very
authentic and and educational that was
pretty much the way that system worked
yeah it wouldn't have been funny if it
wasn't based in truth well yeah well and
like I said you know the book that
Kubrick was initially adapting wasn't
funny like it was a serious it wasn't
like it was a thriller but it was based
on real [ __ ] and he was just like this
the absurdity of it just like struck me
and I decided to make it a black comedy
but it's based in reality yeah that's
what makes it funny it was called wing
attack plan R yeah the wing attack
planar so yeah so the Criterion I don't
know how much it costs but I was like
looking at it going oh man that's so
cool like I love that little the little
bible Russian phrase book thing and like
the all the essays being in those little
envelopes with r on it and so I was like
that's so [ __ ] awesome I just love
that but um can we also I don't think
we've even hardly talked about George C
Scott who I mean Peter Sellers is
amazing amazing in this like in his
three roles
um but George C Scott he [ __ ] kills
it and knocks it out of the park and
here's the other another funny thing
this is and I don't know if this is true
but this is like one of the classic
stories that's told about this movie so
George C Scott gets brought in to do it
and he was initially supposed to play it
like more straight or like more like
George C Scott's type of character
what Kubrick did though Kubrick wanted
him to go more Broad and more comedic so
what he would do is he would say well
just for practice why don't you do the
same scene but like do it kind of over
the top and funny I'm not gonna film it
though I'm not gonna vote it's just a
practice but then he did film it and
those are the takes that he used and
apparently George C Scott was really
really mad when he saw like the final
film because he's like the I didn't
think that he was filming those takes
those were like the over-the-top comedic
takes and I kind of did a lot of it
straight I don't know if that's true but
I've heard that from like a lot of
people because he actually didn't want
to he still liked Kubrick but he didn't
want to work with him again after
because he thought that was like [ __ ]
up that he did that but I have to say
that like his whole over-the-top thing
in this movie is so so funny like that
one scene where he just like keeps
popping gum in his mouth and like
[ __ ] chewing all the damage oh my God
he's like so so fun okay so who was Khan
who was correct the president or Bucky
who called it really
well they both failed both of their
plans failed because they didn't know
about the doomsday device
but had the doomsday device not been
there
it would have been safer to go with
Bucky's plan so which was what Ripper
wanted
Ripper launched because he said okay
guys the I commenced the launch you got
no choice now you guys are going to have
to fully commit if not the uh there's
you know you won't survive the
retaliation
the president's plan of trying to recall
the the planes in reality with the
amount of time that they had
would have been a [ __ ] very risky
chances are you wouldn't recalled them
all and you still would have suffered a
[ __ ] massive retaliation more
Americans would have died
I mean in the context of the movie it
would have worked if that one plane
hadn't had uh you hadn't had their race
yeah but the thing is is that it was
only a movie
in reality
the amount of time that they had it they
wouldn't have had a Time
re plans never survive [ __ ] contact
with reality you want to go with the
dumbest most caveman plan
those tend to to work they're faster
easier and more effective I would have
gone with Bucky's [ __ ] decision just
full in just hit him hit the Soviet as
hard as they could to minimize the
retaliation because you haven't you're
choosing between
20 million American Dead and like
120 million American Dead you want to go
for 20 million American Dead not 120
million it was
that would be the way to go that would
be much easier and faster and more
assured than recalling them
recall on them would have you wouldn't
have been able to recall them and the
Soviets would have [ __ ] retaliated
anyway
remember they only had 20 minutes
well now see I don't know the chances
again I don't know about 20 minutes I'm
just saying that when like when George C
Scott's character first comes in it says
25 minutes I'm assuming until they were
picked up by radar until they were
picked up but here's the deal you had to
get the recall codes all right yeah but
I mean they had already been talking to
the premier so they knew that it was a
mistake but they were just trying to
like figure out yeah I don't think it
would have mattered no I'm just saying
that in the context of the movie they
already knew that it was a mistake so
the the Soviets would have launched even
if it was a mistake
and then uh because they're a machine
too
they're just gonna have their their
response is going to go everything was
preset was like a damn Mutual
destruction machine
so Bucky was actually right I just hit
him with everything and just [ __ ]
hope for the best because recalling I'm
rude and it worked because you never
would have got those recall codes the
whole idea of some British guy going oh
well he wrote them down it must be this
that
putting that many lives on such a damn
coincidence nah
with that in reality in reality there
would have been no way to get the recall
codes because
Ripper wouldn't have written him down he
wouldn't have repeated them in in a real
situation it's just it was a movie there
had to be a way to get the recall codes
so that's how they did it
um but it didn't matter
there was the doomsday device
so it was the same
apparently too this movie was supposed
to end with a big pie fight in the war
room
and there's still photographs of it they
did shoot it
um Buffet there so they were yeah yeah
yeah they said you could see you could
see that so it's supposed to end in a
pie fight but then they decided not to
not to do that the one scene that's
great with George C Scott where he's
just like talking and then like trips
and falls and then like gets up uh yeah
that was apparently an accident and
Stanley Kubrick thought it was
hysterical so he left it in yeah because
he didn't break character yeah because
he didn't break character look at the
big board they just left it in there
because when we were watching I said
that did not look like he did that on
purpose like I'm sure that wasn't
scripted it was real spontaneous yeah
well I think a lot of the stuff in
Kubrick didn't usually do this because
he was like I said he was kind of a
perfectionist this was like an earlier
film but he did actually let like some
uh particularly Peter Sellers like
ad-libbed a lot of stuff particularly
like with the phone conversations and
everything and Kubrick liked it so much
that he just like left it in there and
then just wrote it into the script later
on because he just liked all the Improv
then just another thing that was funny
about the buffet is the the Soviet
diplomat he was a diplomat what he I
think he was a diplomat kiss off yeah I
think yeah
he looks at the buffet and he's got
people got Americans serving him he's
supposed to be like some
Soviet communist socialist type dudes
and he's looking around because no I
would never have a a a Jamaican cigar
made by capitalist Stooges and [ __ ] you
know what I mean but none of the none of
this food is up to Snuff for him you
know none of it's good enough for him he
just ends up having Poached Eggs even
that was like it was all real super fine
food but it wasn't good enough for him
[ __ ] funny
yeah supposed to be a socialist but he's
got these [ __ ] fine tastes he's
turning his nose up our [ __ ] well like I
said everybody gets skewered in there
and since like and everybody is kind of
like everybody's a [ __ ] clown
everybody is kind of like based on sort
of like a real person or not exactly but
it's just kind of like because like I
said the doctor Strangelove character is
mostly based on Burner Von brown but he
was based on like Edward Teller like
some other people too like that they
kind of like put in one conglomeration
and the whole thing about the his one
hand with like the black glove on it
everything that was taken from
Metropolis that right movie
um his hair is he's got the hair is
taken from that too Von Brown had hair
like that though too I know but I'm just
saying that the look of I think the look
was kind of like from uh from Metropolis
mainly but yeah it is to kind of looking
like him too and the accent they said
the accent was actually not what Werner
Von Brown sounded like
um the accent was actually an Austrian
guy that worked on the crew with Kubrick
okay
sellers just did that voice as that
um which I think is great because it's
funny because watching the movie now
because uh you know I watched Mystery
Science Theater a lot and they
referenced Dr Strangelove a lot like
they are always like peppering like
lines from this and particularly like
Servo let's do that my funeral I could
walk you know what I mean like at the
end which some people are kind of like
well what did that mean because I saw
like a couple reviews and they were like
there's a couple of different theories I
I understood it I thought well it's
there's a couple different uh regained
his purpose
yeah well it's so much that it's if
you're going with a sexual reading it's
just like when he's thinking about oh
the world is ending and they're going
down in the in the mine shafts with like
all the women and everything that it
gave him a full body erection I've seen
that one which like I said that kind of
makes sense also I kind of think too
that he got so excited about the
destruction of the world that he stood
up and he wasn't supposed to be standing
up because he could walk the whole time
so he tried to play it off like it was
some big miracle that's what I thought
that's not how I interpreted it I
interpreted it as you know it was now A
Brave New World okay they were gonna go
into underneath under you know
underneath the surface of the Earth and
once again his Nazi skills were being
needed he can now walk he's back you
know because the mine shaft Gap you know
the it's a new war that's that's well
that's kind of like what I said about
like it gave him a full body erection
kind of well I guess like yeah that's
that's the same kind of thing okay
I don't know but I'm just saying that
it's like I'm just saying it's like
metaphoric he's now coming back to life
and metaphorical because they'd Gotten
Good grown kind of powerful and
comfortable in the old ways of the of
the of the that challenge was that
challenge had been met it's that one's
done that mission's done it's a new
Mission now they're gonna go down into
the mine shafts of these girls and worry
about the mine shaft Gap and how to
repopulate the earth once that you know
and the cycle begins again that's that's
that's how I interpreted it you know
what's great about this movie though is
that I was interested to watch I wanted
to watch some reviews and Analysis of
this movie by really young people like
people in their 20s or 30s who who were
not even like a twinkle in anyone's eye
like when all of this stuff was going on
and interestingly a lot of the reviews
and analyzes that I saw that were
actually like really really good and
like really pointed
um and a lot of people that really love
this movie were like young were like in
their 20s and 30s so even though yeah it
helps if you know about the Cold War and
you know about kind of like the politics
of the time and everything like that
like it's funnier if you know the
context but the fact that people that
weren't even alive back then and maybe
just learned about learned about it at
school or whatever like still think it's
funny and that's a real Testament to
like it's staying power yeah well part
of that is is that the uh
the philosophy of mutual destruction is
not just the Cold War that's not
everything yeah what's going on so it's
yeah it's kind of like it's not yeah
it's of its time but it's it could be
extrapolated to the modern era as well
right that they're they're showing the
the 1960s application of Soviet Union
versus the American Empire that same
philosophy is being applied in other
ways today it's just part of the what
governments and think tanks and [ __ ]
intelligence agencies and what the
military-industrial complexes of all the
empires do this is how they are This Is
How They think
it's a systematic mode of thinking
it's just uh they camouflage it they'll
they're cap they've camouflaged it now
in different descriptions and words and
they dress it up to not look military
and to not look
threatening to make a sound the
[ __ ] aren't wearing uniforms
now they'll just wear v-neck sweaters
and [ __ ] and [ __ ] have soft hairdos
and [ __ ] use different wordings and
[ __ ] and try to make everybody feel
comfortable but it's that same thinking
they've just camouflaged it
so I'm just saying it's like it's
interesting that like you know that a
lot of like uh younger people are still
into this movie so it still absolutely
does hold up and like I said I still
think it's not my favorite movie of
kubricks but it's definitely up there
and I was like really glad that I got to
watch it again because it's funny as
hell and I just like laughed my [ __ ]
ass off at it uh but yeah it's actually
on to be for free at the moment if you
want to watch it so holy [ __ ] you don't
have to pay anything to watch it I don't
even know if it's on any other streaming
services at the moment but I just like
found it on 2B last night I was excited
because I wanted to see it but yeah I
mean I kind of feel like most of the
people that be watching this video have
already seen it but if you haven't let
us know what you think about it like
what you know why haven't you seen it or
if you have seen it did you like it did
you think it was funny or what uh so
yeah let us know in the comments and we
will see you guys again on the next
movie retrospective see you later